merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
santé et de la prévention la France
connaît un point de non-retours de notre
système de santé ma question vous paraît
peut-être redondante vue et revue oui
mais malheureusement elle est toujours
au cœur des préoccupations de chaque
citoyen et son importance et capitales
comment ne pas en avoir conscience cela
ne dépasse pas un jour au cours duquel
nous ne sommes pas sollicités à ce sujet
et que répondre
urgence hôpitaux médecine de ville et de
proximité tous se sont incompris face à
la pénurie de soignants à la saturation
au sein de leur établissement ainsi que
leurs conditions de travail dégradées et
quand il propose des projets visant à
améliorer les systèmes de santé ils ne
sont bien souvent pas soutenus ou
n'entre pas dans les cases des projets
de l'État nous n'en sommes plus aux
réponses mais aux actes un objectif
commun avec des mécanismes adaptés à
chaque territoire dans mon département
nous formons le personnel soignant et
quelques mois plus tard il part
travailler en Suisse voisine des
exemples tels il en existe des dizaines
pour chaque département pour soigner
notre le système de santé plusieurs
leviers ayant du bon sens dès demain
libérons les médecins de consultation
inutiles telles que celles pour
récupérer une ordonnance et respecter le
parcours de soins imposer revenons au
choix de médecins libres redonnons des
conditions de travail digne revalorisons
les salaires et les consultations
réduisons les tâches administratives et
une action qui aurait dû se faire hier
réintégrons les soignants non vaccinés
mais que cherchez-vous les
professionnels de santé ne sont pas
responsables des erreurs de la politique
de santé émoignée par les gouvernements
successifs et qui ont conduit à la crise
actuelle notre pays s'enlise dans des
politiques inefficaces qui ne
parviennent pas à soigner les maux de
notre système de santé il en faut d'ores
et déjà le constat le plan annoncé
récemment ne suffira pas je vous le
demande monsieur le ministre quand
allez-vous réellement engager des
responsabilités des actions efficaces et
durables pour notre santé